there's big news earlier this week or
this past week when half a million
people signed up for getter they they
started just leaving twitter in droves a
lot of people said that it was joe rogan
who led the charge some news articles
said that joe rogan joined together
after dr robert malone was banned and
marjorie taylor green was banned i don't
know if it's one or the other i
certainly think both instances played a
big role in this and uh well we got a
lot to talk about around censorship
around that big story and around a bunch
of other stories there's a bunch of
crazy stuff going on in the world as per
usual we've got a manhattan d.a saying
he's not going to seek jail time unless
someone's committing a violent defense
and not even any part like violent
defense basically people are now asking
so according to this d.a kidnappers
child abduction no jail time that's how
insane things are getting in politics in
this country so we'll talk about that we
got emanuel macron questioning the
citizenship of the unvaxxed and we are
being joined by marjorie taylor-green hi
so happy to be here absolutely do you
want to introduce yourself for those who
might not know who you are well if you
don't know me i'm i'm not sure what
you've been doing because the media has
been attacking me now for about a year
you know we're here at the anniversary
um my name is marjorie taylor green i am
from georgia i represent georgia's 14th
district
very proudly very thankful for everyone
at home and um i guess what can i say
i'm
married been married for 26 years i've
got three awesome kids they're all grown
up 24 22 and 18 years old and
my background is commercial construction
and um then i decided to run for
congress because
i don't like what's happening
in washington d.c well it is an honor
and a privilege to have you here
discussing everything that's going on uh
today and giving your insight into the
inner workings of some of the stuff
you're telling us before the show which
we're gonna get into would would make
the average american's jaw drop like how
the whole system works yes well that's
been my experience this entire past year
i i'd never been involved in politics
before um wasn't elected at the state
level i i really had no interest in it i
was just busy living my life i had a
great life before i decided to run for
congress and um so actually
for me
becoming a member of congress you got to
remember january 3rd i swore in that's
when that's when we started and then
things hit the fan quickly
january 3rd i swore in and we passed
rules for the 117th congress this is
something that people don't know happens
uh congress votes on rules for two years
that the entire session
and um there were crazy rules in there
like the part of the rules of course i
voted no against them was they
completely got rid of uh gender uh and
and pronouns and so i was like that was
pelosi right yeah let's get into all
this stuff yeah we will yeah people are
gonna but there's other stuff you were
mentioning too yeah we got luke here i
definitely believe this is going to be a
somewhat interesting conversation to say
the least how you doing my name is
lucardoski of we are change.org riding
shotgun here and uh i think the shirt
i'm wearing is also very appropriate for
uh today's guest which says if you trust
the government you don't know history
and if you want this shirt you could get
it on the best political shirts.com
because you do i'm here i'm super
excited about this conversation thanks
for having me yeah yeah i came in hot to
this conversation asking questions seems
like wait that's what the show's about
slow down i'm happy you're here marjorie
this is gonna be great thank you
i am also super stoked to be here i
think that tonight's conversation is
gonna be awesome marger taylor green's
people reached out to me because they
wanted to bring her onto the show and
we're gonna talk about this ridiculous
censorship that's been happening to her
and i'm stoked so let's go yeah and that
that i want to talk about too that we've
we've talked to other politicians people
active and and running and
i'll i'll tell you our experiences with
them later on before we get started
though head over to timcast.com become a
member help support our work and as a
member you'll get access to exclusive
members only segments of the tim cast
irl podcast we are going to have around
11 pm we will upload a members only
segment the uncensored unfiltered
conversation with marjory taylor green
because as you know we try our best but
youtube absolutely has insane rules and
as we're getting into the 2022 cycle you
know they're going to be ban happy so
we'll do our best but we will have that
uh that conversation up on the website
around 11 or so pm and don't forget to
like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and i'll just briefly mention you might
notice my my voice a little hoarse this
morning when i woke up i was i i decided
to take off my normal morning show
because i'd rather be doing this show
and i didn't want to strain myself so
i'm a little i'm a little rough but
let's just get into the news so uh we're
hanging out with marjorie taylor green
you recently got permanently banned from
twitter i did it led to it contributed
largely and uh to people jumping over to
getter which is another twitter platform
now it's a twitter-like platform
microblogging site right some people
have concerns that getter is going to
have censorship as well because they
have similar rules but uh aside from you
is also dr robert malone a scientist and
a dissenting voice in the whole you know
covid uh
vaccine debate
joe rogan then joins it becomes his big
story half a million people sign up so i
i want to get a better understanding of
this
why do you know why you got banned from
twitter
well we'll we'll go with the story okay
so here's what happened um you know i'm
an elected member of congress which
means the people elected me from my
district over 700 000 people are in my
district and i'm there to represent
their voice their values and and what
they want um out of their representative
uh in congress
and twitter being a private company um i
don't know why they have decided that
they can be the judge of information and
misinformation but that is that's who
they have become i mean that's what we
see on most uh social media platforms
youtube also
facebook many of them and and over time
over the past years we've seen
conservatives be kicked off right this
has been a major issue and it's it's an
extremely important issue for many
americans
so on twitter um this was my personal
account it's it's my campaign account
this is what i use to raise money this
is what i i used uh part of my
reelection so it's very important for me
i have two twitter pages one of them is
my congressional page that's for my
congressional office it's an official
site and then i have this other one that
is the one that i i just got permanently
banned on
so it's it i'm not really sure what
happened but i want to go into it um
i had posted on january 1st a really
long twitter thread uh it was 20 20
tweets i believe and it was all about i
i started it it's 2022
and i i framed it as let's talk about
before covid and after covid and i said
it's like we have a new era that we've
moved into
and so each tweet i went through things
saying before covid and i would give
like what our reality was before covid
like um you know people didn't go to the
doctor unless they were sick i mean that
was what we used to do um as a mom i've
raised kids i didn't take my kids to the
doctor to get a strep test unless they
really had symptoms like a fever sore
throat and things like that so i was
saying before kovid this is how we lived
and then after covid now we we get
tested all the time for for covid and so
i went through every tweet had that but
involved in each of these tweets i put
um information that that i had found in
research like um information off of
vares which is uh cdc.gov
controls that that's the the it's a site
where people can it's self-reporting um
they can report if they've had a vaccine
injury any kind of vaccine not just
covet any kind of vaccine or even a
death
family members or a doctor can report a
death from any kind of vaccine so i had
talked about the bear system and uh
which is bothersome to me there's no
investigation into
the deaths that have been reported on
bears and as a member of congress i
think it's extremely important um so i
had this long tweet thread but then the
next day
i tweeted a few more things
um i had tweeted i had retweeted
someone's tweet about from a person that
was
celebrating and memorializing the
terrorist solomani that was that was
killed uh when president trump was our
president um this was a terrible
terrorist that had you know attributed
and caused the death of military members
and the loss of limbs um when they were
over there and it's awful
and this person was just celebrating him
and his life and angry at president
trump that's on twitter
a lot of it oh yeah and i had retweeted
that condemnation of how can this guy be
on twitter then i had seen a fox news
interview of one of my colleagues one of
my republican colleagues dan crenshaw
and as a member of congress we debate
policy right we should debate policy i i
would love to debate policy with all of
my colleagues
and he was on a in an interview and he
was talking about fema and he was saying
president joe biden wants to do a lot of
testing and he was saying we should use
fema to set up and do this coveted
testing and then he was also saying we
should use fema to go into the hospitals
to help with the overcrowding um
and that's that was what he was saying
we should do but here's the thing i
completely disagree with him and i know
for a fact that republicans and
conservatives and i would even argue
many americans would be against the use
of fema to just continue test and test
and test for covid
um uh because we should be more
concerned about how to treat covid these
are just my opinions not that i'm giving
medical advice but just my opinions
and so i had tweeted at dan crenshawn i
had said um no we don't need to use fema
to do more cova testing for sneezes
coughs and runny noses and i said and we
don't need to send fema into hospitals
we need to rehire the unvaccinated
healthcare workers that were fired and
they are
in some places some places thank god
because these people worked on the front
lines and they they save people's lives
and they have natural immunity that's my
opinion i think it's great and they need
to be able to continue their careers and
and support their families so that the
dan crenshaw tweet was the last one you
put out and then they sus they just i
had one more i i had to pick at aoc a
little bit because you know she was down
in miami enjoying free florida
and martinis and i was like oh that's a
cup full of hypoc hypocrisy oh yeah
she's uh she's tweeted before that texas
removing the mask command date was going
to you know cause suffering i i i don't
want to i don't have the exact quote i
read the other day paraphrasing she said
it was a bad thing basically she said
that ron desantis could use some tips
from the governor of new york wow but
she's going to florida
no mascon the thing is if she really
believes in mask mandates she could
choose to wear one
well let me tell you something yeah and
she doesn't always wear one and
but not i don't i don't i don't want to
right right i don't want to derive i
mean i see her at work so but i'm
curious uh look it's it's 2022.
elections are coming up and
we saw what twitter did with hunter
biden's laptop story right for those
that aren't familiar a huge breaking
story about hunter biden the son of the
president uh and and
just malfeasance i'll put it that way
the story gets suppressed on facebook
and twitter and there are polls showing
that if people had known about the
corruption then a decent amount of
people would not have voted for joe
biden that gets suppressed i'm wondering
if your suspension is just following
it's some kind of political tactic it's
political and here i want to tell you
why so the reason why i bring up dan
crenshaw the tweet is because i told him
this you're not conservative you're
hurting our brand because conservatives
don't promote the use of fema for
testing and
unvaccinated healthcare workers being
fired we don't want that and it was it
was within an hour after that tweet that
i got uh permanently banned from twitter
now here's something interesting
everybody always talks about politics
and money right so they were saying that
i was being kicked off for covered
misinformation but um you know i started
wondering i'm like why is some people's
political speech accepted
and and promoted on twitter whereas
other people's political speech is not
accepted and as a matter of fact is
kicked off and i think that's an issue
so i started looking at who's on the
board at twitter and most of them are
democrats and most of them donate to
democrat politicians
but there's also someone that's
relatively new to twitter his name is
paul singer and he's a he's a mega donor
for republicans um and so i had
looked into some information on him and
i was like wow does he donate to dan
crenshaw
turnout he he does donate to dan
crenshaw as a matter of fact he donates
a lot of money um to dan crenshaw i
would argue that he helped him get
elected by the amount of money that he
donated to him he also donated to a pack
that has benefited dan crenshaw um it
was money spent on his his election and
so
i think it was called the american
patriot pac um it supports a lot of
veterans running for congress and it
that pac had spent hundreds of thousands
of dollars on his behalf i think i do
have it here unless i'm wrong there's
opensecrets.org it says uh singer paul
new york 2700 to dan crenshaw right and
then and that's just a single
contribution i don't know if that's
usually a max contribution i think the
max contribution's gone up now to 2 900
per candidate but you know this is this
is commonplace so he's a mega donor but
i want you to think about this this is a
guy that came on to twitter and it's
very interestingly
he was so important he was able to get
jack dorsey removed from his own company
wow
that's who paul singer is
of elliott management and him coming on
to twitter
was
he he bought a lot of the shares he
became a major shareholder and then him
coming on board he was able to kick jack
dorsey out of his own company i think
that's significant and then this is a
guy that donates a lot of money to
politicians and so and he's not a fan of
mine and he's also not a fan of former
president
he's not giving you any money oh no no
no he wouldn't give me money because i
don't
say and do the types of things he
supports
so i can't prove this this is just
something i'm talking about because i
think these are the type of things that
do play
a role behind the scenes and i think
they're important i really do and i'm
saying that
not only as a member of congress
i'm saying that as an american also and
i think that when twitter has overgrown
uh its position and i really believe it
has because twitter is controlling
political speech
absolutely controlling political speech
not just for american citizens
but for members of congress and i would
say that's that's actually an attack
that is actually a political attack
against my brand of politics um i know
paul singer hates president trump he was
a big fan of marco rubio and that is
that's an open open known thing so they
i'm not really sure but i i don't think
that it was just covered missing no i i
think it's political and i think some of
it is
it's not just twitter it's youtube as
well there's there's stuff that we can't
talk about on youtube youtube would shut
the stream down in two seconds of course
and that's wrong so we're we're not
having real
real political discourse in this country
when the the common spaces that we use
twitter facebook youtube etc are in the
control of one political you know one
political faction that's right and they
just say well you broke the rules the
private platform i can do what i want my
it's crazy to me because i grew up
liberal and we were always complaining
about big corporations suppressing the
commons and and hurting the little guy
in the working class yeah you know what
i feel the same way now i'm watching it
happen yeah and worse it's affecting
politics like
you are a sitting member of congress and
your voice people need to hear it so
they know what you're saying when you're
there voting on things and twitter's
like no we don't think that's important
well i'll tell you what i have a term
for it i'm i'm sorry real quick it's on
the twitter twitter it's not sitting
there saying we don't think it's
important they're saying
it is important and we better not let
people hear it yes no exactly so i have
a term for what you're talking about i
call it corporate communism
and corporate communism is something i
just made up because it made sense to me
it's these large corporations
controlling
and usually they're affiliated with the
government so take for example you've
got a mega donor a republican mega donor
on twitter that hates me
and likes other types of republicans
that are different than me
and so
wouldn't he play a part in getting me
kicked off let's get rid of her we got
rid of president trump they're hurting
the type of republican brand that we
want i think this is really scary and
here's something that's great here's
what i know about all americans
when you sit down and talk to each other
we all care about the same thing we do
most of us care about
we can find so much in common together
by being able to have these discussions
on these platforms then we can really
find apart from one another and that's
why i think censorship is so wrong well
i think the biggest problem with it is
we've we've gone through a bunch of
different uh forms of data showing
people who are on the left in america
whatever that means like the general
term
only get their news from lifting sources
and people who are centrist or
right-wing get their news from a mixture
of sources
so when you have people on the left and
the only thing they've ever heard about
you it comes from the new york times or
the atlantic or something they think the
worst craziest oh
crazy things and if you censor those if
they censor you
well then how are people actually going
to hear what you think
you can't and so there's this view of
you especially if like you pulled your
wikipedia page that's just it's insane i
want you to know i have kept that there
as a badge of honor that's awesome
because wikipedia is just it's whatever
anybody types on there and i think
people should know that about wikipedia
it's not truth um i've never tried to
change it it's it's what other people
have gone and written about me nothing
that i've ever written about myself or
or even that i've cared to make sure is
is factual and i've left it there and
for a reason because i want to be able
to prove to people that look wikipedia
is someone else's words it's just like a
fake news article written about me or
someone else and that's the craziest
thing to me is how
well i've talked to james o'keefe
wikipedia in these articles it says from
wikipedia it doesn't say from random
users like these these statements may be
an aggregate of different people putting
it together wikipedia puts their name on
it so i think they should be held liable
for defamation i totally agree with you
i agree with you 100 and here's the
thing about wikipedia is let's say that
i wanted to fight it i could i could
have one of my staff go on there every
single day and fix it and and correct
the misinformation someone else can go
on there and change it again yeah so
yeah with wikipedia putting their name
on it they are the ones liable for the
lies and slander uh libel and slander
about about people so let's take this
opportunity as uh you know all of us
here on the show we have dealt with the
issues of censorship
um
de-ranking that it's not just that
they'll ban you it's that you'll get
demonetized they will make it harder for
people to find your content and we have
an opportunity now to have discussion
with a sitting member of congress who
has also experienced this
what can be done right i mean
i don't know if you have the power in
congress to make something happen or if
there's a legal pathway towards ensuring
people have access to different
platforms many on the left have jokingly
you know or not even necessarily
jokingly but said haha you want to
nationalize private businesses or
whatever
some people on the right say why should
the government intervene in a private
corporation that wants to make its own
decisions my view has always been more
you know i guess american liberal if a
big corporation takes over a common
space then there's got to be some
regulation but i'm wondering you know
what could we do and and what can you do
what can politicians do just do we have
solutions to this i think that i think
you're bringing up a great a great topic
and it needs to be discussed and as a
member of congress i definitely want to
hear what you've been through um trying
to run a business on social media all of
you try to do it this is where you earn
your income and it's valuable uh not
only for you but for the people that
that sign up and and are
are your members and want to hear what
you have to say in the content they want
to contribute by their comments i think
it's so important here's here's what i
think i
i'm a small government person so i and
i'm a business owner i've been a
business owner all my adult life i grew
up in a small business my family had a
commercial construction company i bought
that business from my parents
when i got out of college and so that my
parents could retire and my husband and
i have run it together for over 20 years
so as a business owner i know what it's
like to deal with government regulations
believe me i don't think it's fun um now
but we're talking about something
different when it comes to this platform
when you are censored
and when your ability to earn earn an
income
uh on these platforms is taken away from
you that that is very troublesome you
need to be defended and you should be
defended uh of course
by the government if no one else is
willing to do it i was thinking about
something you know a lot of people a lot
of these democrat voter and activist
types say it's a private company they
can do what they want right well that's
the excuse sure uh um
uh
my old landlord is a private business
owner it's his building he can do what
he wants right no in fact there's laws
preventing eviction and so i was
thinking about that if we're entering
this this new metaverse world that mark
zuckerberg wants and they expect us to
earn a living remotely earn a living
online then there should be
regulations very similar to eviction
laws and that's in my opinion and i've
never been a conservative like i've
always been sort of on the smaller
government side but kind of in the
middle
i got no problem with regulating massive
multinational billion dollar
corporations with saudi investment that
want to take away my ability to speak
you know so i look at
twitter
there should be eviction laws if you
want to remove from someone from the
platform well look if if you're a
building owner and one of your tenants
commits a very serious crime yeah the
police are going to take them out of
that building and you've got to worry
about it of course but if you want to
evict them because you're complaining
about he was saying nasty things to
other neighbors will go to court yeah
because renters have rights
so here's something interesting as a
political figure
when i was on twitter i was sued
yeah so i don't know if a lot of people
know about this i was sued by a pack
called my midas touch and i was sued
because we we blocked them we blocked
them because they were being nasty to me
and this was in the very beginning when
i first got there i think it was in
january
i didn't know that i couldn't block
people people were saying terrible
things about me people would
threaten my family threaten my children
threaten my life post porn all kinds of
gross things why can't i block that i
mean i'm a woman i it's i don't want to
have my life threatened or my children's
life threatens was that your personal
account that's on the one that got
banned no it's also it was my campaign
account oh i see i see but because i'm a
public figure i i was open for lawsuits
it had it's happened to aoc
um you know she had to deal with the
same thing uh president trump was sued
uh i think there was a sheriff in
california with suit it's happened to
quite a few people but when you become a
public figure
you you become in this new land of uh
you're not allowed to have a lot of
rights anymore i think specifically if
you're um a public official
public yes public official yes elected
so that became an issue um but then you
know going back to what you're talking
about yes there should be
real they would say the user agreement
that's what they would say is is what
binds everyone on twitter and other
social media platforms
but in reality it i think there needs to
be more than that and and honestly when
it comes to censoring political speech
um you can't sit here and and and you
know how they'll uh put people in
twitter jail and they'll cite german law
yeah i'm sorry oh yeah i had that i
don't have to obey german law i'm an
american to be fair
that uh
twitter won't ban you in the united
states for german law they're required
to inform you of german law some of this
i actually think is a courtesy and is a
good thing people will get a
notification saying you know you've been
found in violation of pakistani law and
then i see a lot of people say why is
twitter telling me this and i'm like i i
would i would prefer to know that
because then i won't fly there because
you know
yeah yeah but but i will i will uh segue
into this bit um
and going back to what we were saying
about you know where i was asking
possible solutions possible solutions
dan crenshaw said he had a potential
solution to this and he was criticizing
you
he was he so he was attacking me really
because he was very upset with me um you
see there's a there's a back story um
we kind of don't get along very well in
congress and and i don't i don't have
any problems with that i didn't i didn't
run for congress to become friends with
people i'm perfectly happy with all my
friends and family i have back home i
ran for congress because i felt like i
couldn't trust my government and i felt
like our government is failing the
american people luke's got a shirt for
that yes i was going to also ask
wait where do people buy that shirt the
best political shirts dot com
it says if you trust the government you
don't know history yeah that's a very
important lesson that of course a lot of
people know i don't want to interrupt
you but i just want to i just wanted to
make sure we get
dan crenshaw said he had a bill that
would stop the censorship or something
like that absolutely so there's a lot of
bills there's tons of bills republican
and democrat bills um i'd i want to look
at all the options before i put my name
on them i'm one of those people that i'm
not just going to go oh oh look gov um
big tech censorship bill boom here's my
name i'm not going to do that i'm used
to uh
reading
contracts in detail before i sign them
that's what i did in business so this is
the same way i look at bills we should
read them in detail as members of
congress not rely on our staff read them
and then we put our name on them or or
if we're voting for them we really
should know what they have to say it
should be federally mandated it should
be a federal offense for someone to vote
on something they didn't read i totally
agree
i totally agree that's something i've
worked on this year i'd love to tell you
about it yeah well the big tech lobby is
also very big do you think anything is
possible when they're having so much
money invested into dc and did you
personally have anyone come to you from
big tech trying to lobby you in effort
and what else can you say about this
kind of generality i think that's a
great question so
for everybody watching if you don't know
i
have been the most attacked member of
congress probably in history i got
kicked off of all of my committees on
february 4th of this past year so being
a committee-less
freshman member of congress the
lobbyists haven't been too interested in
me and that's okay because um i don't
take their money anyways yeah but the
big but the big tech lobby is very big
they do and they really want to talk to
members of congress because we make laws
and we also um have oversight we have
oversight committee we we investigate
issues we question i mean you've seen
people have seen mark zuckerberg there
they've they've seen jack dorsey there
question and question on these issues so
yes they pay a lot of money to lobbying
firms because they want so it's like
sales okay so let's go let's go to the
real world so in sales if you're in
corporate sales or you're selling
widgets for whatever your business are
you want to go in and you want to talk
to people about here's what i'm selling
here's my product you know you're going
to love it this is what these big
companies do they hire lobbyists so the
lobbies go in talk to the members of
congress talk to the senators and go hey
listen here's our here's what our
company is about these are the things
that that really help our customers this
is what really helps us to continue to
be able to do business and it's a whole
friendship thing
um but they pay money for people to go
do that but they invest a lot of money
and just really quickly with how much
influence and control they have do you
think any kind of action against them is
possible in congress i want to tell you
i think they have a massive amount of
control and it's dangerous yeah look
here's for me i'm one of the top
fundraisers
out of republicans which is incredible
because i don't have committees
i've been attacked and lied about
constantly the mainstream media has
created a monster that they want
everyone to think i am and that's what
they constantly talk about
but here here's what happens so because
of that my only donations are small
dollar donations i'm not kidding you
it's the regular working man and woman
will send me twenty dollars and i'm like
these are the best people on the planet
god bless them i don't get the big
checks i don't get the lobbyist i don't
get that stuff so you want to know what
i think about that
it is the most freeing thing in the
world because i'm supported by average
americans now most members of congress
don't get those small dollar
contributions like i do i've raised a
lot of money i think in the past year
i've raised something like
seven million dollars i don't know it's
a lot of money for a member of congress
in the first quarter of 2021 you raised
three million dollars even vox called it
incredible fundraising though they used
that as a smear against you and the
republicans of course was a lot of money
yes they were bad republicans but it's a
lot of money but that's from regular
americans i didn't get that from
lobbyists um but here's most but to
understand this most members of congress
rely on those big checks from lobbyists
or pacs or big donors and they spend
time calling and calling and calling
asking for their support talking to them
because it's important you have to have
money it's like a business to run a
campaign so is any action possible and
if it was what action would you take as
a member of congress if you could pass a
law right now regulating this internet
landscape what kind of provisions would
you put forward so i again i'm a small
government person so i'm one of those
people that's going to say like hey like
if we go eat and we're at this
restaurant and say me and you eat there
every wednesday night and i always order
the cheeseburger and you order like the
chili dog but that probably upset your
stomach so i'd be like dude don't order
that but i'll do it anyway yeah
you know me too well yeah
okay so we go there every wednesday
night but every single time we're
disappointed because the service really
sucks they treat us bad the the food is
terrible and we and then by the end of
the meal we're talking about like why do
we keep coming here that is what it's
like on twitter that is what it's like
on these social media platforms that
treat us terrible and and don't allow us
to really have free speech like we're
having
right now even though we're still
limiting what we could say
but here's what i think what if we said
hey next wednesday night let's go try
this restaurant across the street it's
new it's different i mean who knows i
heard they have cheeseburgers and chili
chili hot dogs so like what if we go
over there see i'm one of those people
and this is why i love new ideas and new
pl this is why i went to get her
i went to get her and i was like let's
go try this out to correct you it's
chili cheese dogs
dogs but this would be a cultural
solution something that i mean we've all
advocated trump should have done when
when he was president he should have
just signed up for he should have signed
up for gab i think he should have went
he should have put his posts on gab that
would have sent a huge message to the
mainstream media
for you he didn't do it
i i can respect let's also say maybe it
had to do with the staff because i can
tell you now
people think that people like president
trump or people like me or someone else
that people like in in politics they
think that we have all day long and we
control all of it we don't i mean we
can't who can do everything
this is why when i asked about
censorship i you know i said can you
even do anything right because i i kind
of i'm going to tell you no because i'm
going to be really honest right here i'm
going to tell you something i got really
angry because i got disappointed in
republicans that's why i ran for
congress i was like republicans didn't
do anything they told me they were going
to do on the campaign trail they very
much disappointed me
and when i saw republicans fail when we
had a republican president the white
house
republican-controlled
house of representatives and a
republican-controlled senate that was
from in 27 and 2018 and they didn't
repeal um obamacare i'm sorry if you
support that they didn't repeal it but
that took my family's health insurance
premiums from eight hundred dollars a
month to over twenty 2 400 a month i was
really upset that the republicans who
said they were gonna do something about
it did nothing about it and then i cared
about border security and they didn't
build the wall they didn't even fund it
and i was like wait a minute you guys
all ran for congress on this stuff and i
think there's a lot we need to do about
immigration and i don't always agree
with all the things that have been
thrown out there but they didn't do
anything and i'm very pro-life i'm i'm i
think abortion is terrible i i can't
even as a mom it's so sad to me that
women are sold a lie that they that they
have to have an abortion in order to
have a professional career or to to have
value in any way i think motherhood's
the greatest way to have value but
republicans did nothing so my point is
this going back to censorship no i don't
trust congress to fix it i don't that's
why i'm telling you i believe in the
american people i believe in starting
new companies i believe in starting new
platforms and i believe the people can
solve the problem because we still have
the freedom and the ability to do it the
challenges
with parlor and gab really good examples
uh gab was smeared relentlessly
relentlessly by the press then they had
their infrastructure attacked by silicon
valley parlor was the exact same thing
they lied about them and then the these
big tech companies use the fake news as
as a pretext to go after the
infrastructure right you want to know
why
why is that their competition
but right so so i'll put twitter and
facebook out of business this big tech
lobby and their the media collusion and
they're all working to support the
democratic establishment and to a
certain extent the republican
establishment too not republican
outsiders oh yeah how can a regular
person start up a company and i'll give
a shout out to gab right andrew torber
the founder is great i'm on gab they're
building their own infrastructure god
bless them but but it's crazy that
that's what you have to do because all
of these companies work together to like
they collude it's con it's corporate
communism i'm going to go back to it
over and over let me let me explain i'm
a small business owner that's what i've
always been it is really hard to compete
and bid on projects against big
companies because they have everything
set up so that that was hard for us for
a long time and then we had to work we
had to work harder than anyone to build
our company to a place where we were
like yeah we're landing these contracts
over and over because we've built a good
reputation we've built the relationships
and we're able to do it this is what
this is what gab and getter and and
telegram and these other companies are
up against this is what uh rumble is up
against they're the little guy that has
just gotten in the pond and these giant
fish want to devour them and they're so
evil uh here's what's really bad they
collude together this is why i call it
corporate communism i know it's a weird
idea and people aren't used to it but
communism is control it's control
through government and big corporations
together and they and they become this
really small elite at the top and
everyone else is these little fish down
at the bottom that can never rise to the
level because the media what did they do
they totally trashed uh parlor they
totally trashed gab and and tore them
down and i think they said there was
like oh it's a platform for white
supremacists or something like that um i
i i i agree with you a lot i think it's
a cultural uh it's a cultural change
that needs to happen i think if trump
was just in the middle of his you know
first term said i'm going to go on gab
or mines or something then it would have
forced the media to do it that would
have just put a stake right to the heart
of these vampiric entities he didn't do
it and so perhaps it's just going to be
we have to build up confidence in in
these other platforms ourselves no
matter no matter how hard it's going to
be the problem is if you have a platform
it can ban you at any time that's always
going to be the case and i agree with
you i'm not big government and for the
government to say you can't seems
fascist so i like that they're allowed
to do whatever they want but i think i
have an idea that we can toss around
congress is that if we can force free
software code for social networks that
are super large basically functioning as
part of the commons so that other people
have access to the software code and can
start their own
website with that basically the same
technology is awesome with like the
analytics and the messaging and all that
and build their own terms of service on
their version you can see that we're
communist
yeah
see i was gonna say you guys believe in
limited government i believe in no
government but but we also have to admit
the fact that the government was
involved in building up big tech whether
it's q intel whether it's helping them
build the infrastructure whether it's
google maps i say for me personally
there is action to take give it all back
you took it you took all the tax
incentives you took all the
infrastructure you were able to make
leaps and bounds because of your
relationship with government it ends now
and i think if we just cut off
government from the private sector uh i
think that would be the most important
thing that we could we could do because
there is collusion there are a lot of
lobbyists and they're literally i think
working with intelligence agencies in
such a cohesive way that there's no
separating them from the state and
private entities there's it's nothing
different for me from my perspective
this is my new buddy for dinner on
wednesday night
chili cheese dogs
cheeseburgers let me ask you this uh as
it's campaign season i mean some people
have been campaigning non-stop there's
nothing i feel like that's all we do is
campaigning
but they've just taken away twitter is
one of the biggest social platforms in
the world yeah is it it it when when
they say oh make your own twitter that's
like saying you have there's one major
football stadium of people where
everyone talks and they're going to tell
you go to a high school you know
football field that that that is
here's where i'm getting to
do you have any plans to go after
twitter for unfair election practice or
election interferences or unfair
practices as it pertains to giving your
opponents access to this network and
taking it away from you well i'm going
to say this because i'm still talking
with my attorneys everything's on the
table right now so i don't have an exact
um i can't lay out my exact plan because
obviously we everyone's just coming back
from the holidays
but i'm still in discussions with my
attorneys i think i have a lot of
options and i think twitter has a lot to
worry about um you know and here's why
i'm an elected member of congress and no
one elected twitter and no one appointed
them to be this god of information and
misinformation and so for like dr malone
which is really shocking to me that he
was uh permanently banned
you know i'm not a doctor so i'm not
going to get into the science of of
covered vaccines i don't think it's
appropriate to get into that for me um
but dr malone
played a giant role uh in the mrna
technology for these vaccines i would
think his voice is definitely more
credible than twitter's ability to judge
if he's misinforming the public
isn't there a bit of a contradiction i
mean if if you feel that the government
can't solve this problem
is you know filing a lawsuit to
challenge a private company's decision
to remove you the right path
no i definitely think i'm a big believer
so there's a difference there's a just
our justice system right so we're three
branches of government so you don't
always want to rely on the law making
body that's what i'm a member of
congress that's the law making body um
but the justice the justice system i
believe in and this is i mean this is
one of the reasons why i have really
gotten involved with the pre-trial
january 6 defendants not in their cases
because i'm very much against the riot
on january 6th but i've been very
concerned about how they've been treated
pre-trial because i believe in due
process but i believe in the ability to
take a case to court
and to say here's where i've been
wronged and to be able to then defend
myself and and have necessary action
taken oh wow that's that's that's a
great distinction
um yeah passing a law is very different
from having a court uphold say a
contract or a standard exactly
uh well i suppose it'll be interesting
to see what your your argument i'm you
said you have options on the table it'll
be interesting to see what you you end
up putting forward there's um
uh didn't dr robert malone say he was
going to be suing as well and um there's
a lot of people
yeah it's not just malone it's also
mccullough it's also robert kennedy jr
it's also a hard swap of other doctors
that are getting hit that are getting
censored all over the place whether it's
instagram whether it's youtube whether
it's twitter slowly but surely they're
boiling the frog here and trying to take
away any kind of dissenting voices
creating more establishment echo
chambers and creating a situation where
even just looking in the wrong direction
or burping in the wrong direction will
get you
kicked out of normal society i think
this is all done in collusion with the
2030 vision the kind of social credit
score and these these individuals are
working hand-in-hand with government and
i and i think
i agree with you the private kind of
solution is needed there more than ever
but i think the world the word needs to
get out there but how can the word get
get out there when it's being censored
and controlled on the information
highways by the people who built it so
that's that's such an interesting
paradox that's very difficult but this
is why i may agree with you i may
disagree with you it doesn't matter our
voice still should be heard no matter
what it is and the fact that it's being
censored is just atrocious and the fact
that it's being politicized in such way
it's so obvious what they're doing right
now and i and i think we better wake up
or we're going to be boiling very soon
and i think the first bubbles have
already popped up and and
excuse me but i think you're one of the
big bubbles that came up there you're
making people realize how hot the water
is yeah they ban a sitting president
and trump was you know it was it was the
end of his first term so people said
well you know it's in his first term no
no you're marjorie you're in congress
right now yeah and i have pulled my
polling numbers we just did them a few
weeks ago they're unbelievable i have so
much support in my district
i think it was like 54 percent said they
would elect me no matter who ran against
me
that's really high i had i have like a
70 71 or 72 percent um support rating
there hardly anyone elected has that
type of support so i'm not an outgoing
member of congress i'm very much a
supported member i mean even in that
capacity i mean you there's still
another year basically of you in
congress doing work right and you're
you're going to be affecting federal
laws the people of every every state of
every city every citizen of this country
they need to know what you think and why
you think it and twitter decided to
strip that away from you
that i think is is you want to talk
about lawsuits you want to talk about
personal ethics or fairness all of that
aside twitter is is harming the united
states by doing this i think so too i
see it as a complete attack on our
government it's it's an attack it's not
only attack on our government it's an
attack on over 700 000 people that live
in georgia's 14th district that i'm
supposed to represent this is twitter is
acting as an enemy is it a complete
enemy to do our american
system everything everything the way
it's set up and again i it's corporate
communism i'll say it over and over and
over again this is not how private
companies should act think about this
any other private company that attacked
a member of congress
let's say that i'm somewhere and someone
comes up and puts their hand over my
mouth do you think that something's not
going to happen to them oh believe me
they're going to have serious
consequences to pay well twitter did
that to me did you see the uh it's it
gets brought up a lot because i guess it
was you know people like they enjoyed it
when i was on joe rogan's podcast with
jack dorsey yeah it was great
there was one really important point i
think the most important point was when
i mentioned to jack
they have a policy on misgendering that
policy
is a leftist world view
half the country disagrees with it that
is twitter overtly saying
we will allow left world view and ban
right world view this is going to rip i
told him this in 2018 it was 2018 i
think i said if you keep doing this this
country is going to get ripped apart and
look look where look where we've got
where we've gone with you know people
being shot in the streets with with the
january 6 with just people in this
country are ready are ready to explode
which is so sad because we really
shouldn't be look here's my thing i'm a
big believer there's only two genders
and i don't mean to offend anybody if
some some guy wants to run around in a
dress and he wants to call himself a
woman that's his thing but i'm not going
to call him a woman because i think he's
a man and i don't think you should be
kicked off of twitter just because you
think there's only two genders and
you're kind of going along with uh what
the chromosomes say uh with gender and
sex but no you're right you can't just
force one worldview or one type of
culture or anything that's like saying
oh you're only allowed to be on this
platform if you're a christian well can
you imagine the outrage over that this
is exactly why i've always had a problem
with it when we had a fellow on the show
i said the problem i take with critical
race theory praxis in schools like
actually indoctrinating kids i would
take issue with public schools teaching
uh telling a kid to you know pray the
hail mary five times or whatever if a
public school says we want you to do
this religious practice i'd be like hey
you can go to your you know private
religious practice for this critical
race theory this left world view is a
religion it's very much so so i take
issue with any kind of indoctrination
my view is let teach the kids let them
learn let them develop and think for
themselves teach them how to think
critically teach them history teach them
real history real history let them
figure it out you know give them
guidance but instead what we get are
people who simultaneously claim
that
you know what i'll just be reiterating
your point for twitter to say you have
to agree with our view would be like if
twitter was a christian company that
made leftists agree with the teachings
of the bible or they'd be banned
absolutely that is a thousand percent
what it is they they believe this on on
what they have to say about climate this
is this is what they enforce on on how
they how what you're allowed to say and
what you're not allowed to say or what's
accepted speech about gender um it's
what is accepted speech about say blm
french instance what is accepted to talk
about january 6 twitter literally right
now has something set up for tomorrow
for the anniversary of january 6 for
violence that may be tweeted
so they're not they're only allowing one
view of january 6 and and not maybe
other stories or videos i mean think
about that what if people are wanting to
post their videos
and they're not going to allow it i also
believe there's an element of it that
that is something that is snobby elites
thinking that they could control what
you could listen to and i think that's
one of the most patronizing that's one
of the lowest level kind of thinking
individuals that you could have with
this larger idea that you yourself don't
have any discernment you don't have any
personal responsibility you need to be
told what you can and cannot listen to
that idea is absolutely absurd it's
criminal and and the fact that
individuals control what you could see
when they control the algorithms they
control people's perceptions they
control our views of the world and when
you control that you could control
almost everything and that's why and the
intelligence agencies have been so
involved with big tech and that's why i
i think there's even a bigger play here
that of course is snobby is very elitist
but it's essentially leading to the
divide and conquer agenda and trying to
control individuals by controlling
thoughts and that's crazy i do too i
actually i really agree with you that's
why the world economic forum is
something that i'm that i'm concerned
about um that's another reason why it
bothered me that dan crenshaw who's
supposed to be a republican was uh i
think he was involved in it in 2019. um
so those these are the things that
concern me and i'm not into globalism i
honestly i love america as as our own
country in our own identity not that it
has anything to do with race or religion
or any of that stuff i care about us as
americans um but when you have those
ideas like these globalist ideas that
are that are preached and taught on the
world economic forum um that really
concerns me because they're very
integrated in the people that run
twitter
let me pull this up real quick we have
this from cnbc africa daniel crenshaw
congressman from texas house of house of
representatives usa they say he won a
type political race and this is the
world economic forum young global
leaders pushing boundaries and changing
the world in 2019. yep this is this is
interesting to me i don't know exactly
what this young global leaders thing
means but it does show that daniel
crenshaw was named as in some way
associated with the world economic forum
which as most people are familiar with
has been a proponent of the great reset
a restructuring of global capitalism and
it's they're they're the ones who put
out the video that said you will own
nothing and you will be happy so i'd be
curious to know what this means you know
about what i find
concerning yeah it was an article that
they actually got rid of uh tulsi
gabbard was also a member of this kind
of think tank group uh and one of their
uh chief technology experts the tech
their technology pioneer of the world
economic forum is isabel s maxwell galen
maxwell's sister so there's a lot of
people interconnected with this some
people call this this kind of larger
octopus with tentacles all over kind of
our modern society especially when it
comes to politics but a lot of these
organizations of course
openly talk about what they want and
they've been talking about having people
eat bugs having people living in pods
having people promoting the metaverse
having no privacy having no freedom not
owning anything and allegedly being
happier than ever these are their own
protocols that they're pushing out
they're saying we need to limit people's
travel we need to control their aspects
we need to have a social credit score
it's all out there in their own
documents so we could we can read it and
understand it how do you understand it
because that's
me just ask more specifically uh would
you support us living in pods and eating
bugs oh my god no i don't want to live
in a tiny house i can't live in a tiny
house or a pod no i'm much pickier than
that i want to well so i want whatever
kind of house i have i want you to have
what if you want a pod you can have a
pod i mean there's kind of crazy things
with this here's how i see this so
globalism to me really bothers me
because here let me give you guys a
little story so in my district in
georgia um we're we're a large textile
industry we that's that's a big thing
that's in my district and so there's a
factory and they they used to make and
they still can make it but i'll explain
why they don't make it as much they have
the blue indigo dye that makes blue
jeans okay what is more american than
blue jeans i mean america is that is if
there's a brand blue jeans is it it's
like rock and roll blue jeans that that
was from an era some some decades ago
but that's what we were known for
well this company can't compete they
can't sell their blue jeans that they
make you want to know why
because of globalism because of all of
these these um
decades of failed policies that have
come from our government from
republicans and democrats i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna attack one party it's been
both of them that have sold out american
companies and these american companies
have had to had their goods made their
blue jeans made in other countries like
india or say mexico but here's what's
happened there's a factory that that has
made blue jeans for a long time
they can't sell their blue jeans in
walmart
and here's why this is important this
factory supports 80 percent of the tax
base in this one county in my district
80 percent that's massive they support
the water system they support the school
system they support the fire department
on how much taxes they pay for the
county
but the only store that they can really
shop at is a big big box store
walmart you want to know why in small
towns in rural america all across the
country
small mom and pop businesses have been
put out of business by big box stores
like walmart or dollar generals and
different huge companies like this
here's why it hurts these people that
work at this factory and this factory
that makes its living on on producing
say blue jeans for example
they can't compete they can't sell their
blue jeans in walmart but yet that's
where all their employees and families
have to shop and buy food why can't they
is it walmart won't let them or is they
they can't compete they can't compete
price wise this is what breaks my heart
okay look i i will it's not about
politics to me i care about people i
care so much about people and because i
understand it this is who i am this is
what i come from
uh we've worked hard all our life that's
who i am as a person that's who my
family was
when there's people in a town and they
they work their tail off all day long
they have kids they have families
and they can't they can't sell their own
goods in the store because this store
says no no no you're two dollars too
high
our our person that we buy from over
here in india they're giving it to us
for cheaper you bring your price down
two dollars
guys
mr american factory will buy from you so
it's but until then sorry it's the free
trade stuff when you reference these
policies that have been happening it's
it's it is it is it what it is is it's
the destruction of american american or
american culture of who we are it shreds
the fabric apart here's what happens let
me explain to you over the decades when
our factories and small town i mean
we're talking about steel mills we can
spread it across every industry
over the decades when they have these
small towns have slowly crumbled because
these factories they cannot compete
because of the what's being produced in
china or india wherever they can't
compete you know what that does it
affects people's personal lives here's
why people lose their jobs what happens
when dad loses his job dad is depressed
he becomes an alcoholic what happens
when dad is depressed and he's an
alcoholic mom is frustrated mom and dad
are fighting mom and dad get a divorce
what does that do to the kids when
they're in elementary and elementary
school and middle school it shatters
their lives there has been there has
been a destruction in so many different
levels from us selling out our our own
companies and not allow not having
policies in place that support our
companies and help our companies compete
but instead helping globalism and this
is why i can't stand the ideas on the
world economic forum trump trump was
trying to uh
you know the media talked about trump's
trade wars he was trying to introduce
tariffs there was the famous line
michael moore brought up where trump
said if you make your car in china or
mexico we're going to put a 30 percent
tariff on it don't ever buy it again
do you agree with trump on that or do
you see other solutions to this i i i
view it the free trade as the issue it's
cheaper and you can just chip in the
goods from india or bangladesh or
whatever then we can't compete but is
there a different policy solution that
uses there's a lot of levels to this so
there's the epa the epa has tons of
regulations especially if you're a
company that uh has used chemicals when
you produce your company like the carpet
industry or flooring industry those are
in my district also the epa has tons of
rules so if you manufacture carpet guess
what here's the rules in california so
let's say i make carpet and i sell it to
you
i am responsible for that carpet when
you decide to rip it out of your house
and throw it away
like in 20 years yeah and china doesn't
think about that
china never has to deal with any of
these kind of regulations and i believe
the american people had the rug pulled
out in front of them when rockefeller
and kissinger went to china and opened
up china to the world in exchange for of
course slave labor and getting rid of
all the manufacturing jobs in the united
states so why is our own american
leaders in government helping china
no think about afghanistan
we pulled out of afghanistan you know
what nobody wanted to be in afghanistan
we all wanted out of afghanistan we're
sick and tired of the never-ending
foreign wars i think they're horrendous
we pull out of afghanistan what a
debacle it was such a failure in every
way the one thing i was screaming about
was rare earth minerals
our government you wouldn't believe the
amount of money we invested in rare
earth mineral mines in afghanistan we
built the infrastructure
american taxpayers paid for that
we pull out and guess who is getting
those mining rights china china
you know what you don't want to know
what comes out of rare earth mineral
mining everyone
hey little microchips guess what else
those really awesome electric vehicles
that everybody everybody wants a tesla
oh my god they're so cool hard to get
that oh the tesla truck i think it's
fantastic what is it a cyber truck yeah
my husband cannot wait he's like totally
on i want them to convert their
headlights by the way so that they can
be movie projectors as well so you can
watch they should i mean wow
okay but here's the thing
he'll do it he won't give you a sense
i'm not keep it for yourself i'm not
knocking it on elon musk i'm not
knocking anyone that that is making
these things here's my problem
in the buildback better plan and and the
democrats plan
they want us all americans mr and mrs
american and everybody and you're not
even driving yet kids at home
they want by 2035 every single car in
the united states to be an electric
vehicle here's the trouble china
dominates the rare earth minerals
85 percent of the world's they have the
rights to the world's rare earth mineral
mining
those rare earth minerals are what
produce the battery that runs the
electric vehicle guess where america is
we are less than five percent we're like
at four percent why would our american
government force all of us to be
dependent on china to drive a car these
are failing ideas these these shouldn't
be about republican and democrat this is
selling out americans oh yeah the
federal reserve sold out america and now
it's a subsidiary of the swiss bank of
international settlements and they're
just using this government and probably
economy to death are you familiar with
thucydides trap
it gets brought up on this show pretty
uh regularly but it's it's it what it
means is
when a rising economic power is about to
supplant the dominant power typically
war will break out
so throughout history what uh world
leaders have tried to do is
bribe the opposing power to just give up
so it's basically the way i see it is to
avoid
war world war three you've got special
interests just saying let's sell out
america to china and then there's no war
we do these free trade agreements we
become dependent
the problem is the chinese government's
at war with its people maybe i'm
stepping on the line saying that but
they're like i'm not saying it's a good
thing they're doing it i'm saying
there are people who believe it is
better to sell out the united states to
china because they think it'll avoid a
war i think that's i think that's wrong
i think american people have have rights
i think we should protect the american
worker i think we should secure our
borders i think we should do a i agree
with trump on a lot of that stuff as it
pertains to uh these free trade
agreements and this idea this nebulous
idea that maybe there's war is no excuse
for these billionaire elites to sell us
out i i my opinion is they're they're
using it as an excuse to just empower
themselves you see elon musk everybody
cheers for him but we had pasobika
yesterday saying you know he's he's he's
opening up factories in china and
xinjiang yeah
he's horrible money yeah
but he's up but think does it make him a
bad guy he's using the system so here
i'm gonna i'm gonna give a different
argument i'm not necessarily saying
these people are they're the evil uh
overlords they're using the system to
make money so do we declare someone evil
because they're using the system to make
money i'm gonna i'm gonna argue i'm not
gonna judge them if they're evil or not
what i am gonna say is it's the system
that is failing us
and
president trump i god i love that man i
talk to him every single week sometimes
several times a week um i enjoy going to
visit him and he's absolutely hilarious
i wish the world could see him uh for
who he is and not the the portrait or
the guy that they've created him they
want everybody think he is
he he was the start tim
he was the start and so here's where it
has to go he couldn't fix it all in four
years he just couldn't but he started
things and then we need to build on them
and and maybe change the trajectory or
make it better or build on top of it i
think this is going to take decades to
fix because it's taken decades to tear
down i think we should always expect
better from people and just because
someone's making money doesn't mean you
should criticize them but it doesn't
mean that they can't be doing things
that are better for the world especially
when they're reaching such huge levels
now when trump was in office he also
spent a lot of money and i think
financially one of the things that
really hurts this country is borrowing
money that we don't have trump did this
in a huge huge level did you agree with
some of his spending policies because
that's been a lot of criticism that
people need
uh you know of him and and i haven't
seen much of it to be honest with you uh
you you'll hear it in conservative
circles so i'm a conservative i i'm i'm
a believer in you know fiscal
responsibility because as a business
owner that's what i've always had to do
if we weren't doing things right with
our business then we couldn't pay our
bills and pay our employees that's
number one you have to pay your
employees they're doing work you have to
pay your bills that keeps the lights on
you have to pay your bills that produces
the materials and you're able to serve
your customer in the end that's number
one if you aren't serving your customer
you don't get to continue being in
business and you don't deserve it if
you're too stupid to spend your money
and waste it you don't deserve to be in
business and you don't deserve your
customers loyalty that's how i
personally feel i think the government
should be run like a business i
seriously do i'm like why do we spend
all the money why don't we make a profit
what's wrong with sticking a bunch of
money away what would be more powerful
than american government that wasn't in
debt by like 30 trillion dollars but we
had a lovely little nest egg that we get
to say you know what you mess with
america we're going to spend some of our
savings and we're going to put you
people in your place so leave us alone
that's the kind of that's what i think
we should be doing instead of just
continuing to dive into uh dat i don't
believe in borrowing money to make money
the and it's not just that it's it's the
quantitative easing it's the printing of
money it's the the pumping of money into
the into the monetary system which just
dilutes the savings of the working class
i don't i i think that for too long this
country has just been run by the elites
the oligarchs whatever you call it
plutocrats plutocrats and
and and it's funny because you know uh i
i got my start during occupy wall street
yeah where where is the the mainstream
left to be like hey let's put aside
these petty squabbles and focus on the
fact that there is a dominant
establishment elite that is just
extracting value from the working class
and screwing over the little guy
corporate communism
you know the thing about it is the well
the left they mock you for saying that
corporate communism i know they pick on
me all the time and they but they don't
know what i'm they don't know what i'm
talking about and that's the big problem
i wonder why it is there there are
certain very prominent leftists that
will will argue with me on twitter in
agreement it's the weirdest thing i'll
say something like hey you know you know
maxwell trial and these elites and this
plane and then they'll respond just
arguing with me and i'm like
you're arguing but you agree why is it
friendship no
look that's why i do it friendship
no but but they're they're they're it's
tribalism
you know it's they maybe i was like yeah
tribalism you have to argue with them i
i follow a bunch of these prominent
leftists because i know that there's
strong agreement on populist issues
right right and left have uh and i'll
and they'll tweet something i'll be like
yes and i'll agree with it and and then
all of their fans will respond saying
screw you f you screw you and i'm like
yeah
i don't know how you how do you how you
get past that point you know what i mean
you got to get away from text and get
into video chat that's it's hard to you
know you know you're right
isn't it different when you read
something and you can read one person's
text or one person's tweet and if you
put an angry tone on it because you
don't like them because they're your
political enemy then you automatically
take it the wrong way whereas if if you
read most people if they read my words
if they were hearing them the way i
would speak them they would hear it a
lot differently that's right and
especially when the media sees a
narrative about you for instance that
makes you sound crazy then people they
hear something in their head that is
just a misrepresentation of who you are
of course they make up in their mind who
they think you are yep and then all of a
sudden everything takes a different tone
yeah well let me ask you this so you can
do that to anybody too oh my gosh even
my dad i was getting texts but i was
getting so much text that i was just
like just another text i was like it's
my father come on we've been dude we've
we've had um several people who are
running for office on the show and we've
tried to get
several people who are currently in
office i think i could be wrong but i
think you're the first person who's
actually currently sitting in political
office who's come on the show and uh you
know just the way we were talking
earlier uh before the show started it
just and we'll have that up as a special
episode on the websites the green room
we show the whole behind the scenes
you seem like a regular person
and so uh with that
tell us about what your experience has
been like entering congress
cause um i gotta say a lot of people
probably have this this vision where
like you go in you know it's your first
term and you create a bill and then
everyone stamps it
yeah yeah you were telling us about how
they just like do voice votes yes oh my
gosh i want everyone to know this and if
you hate me you still need to know this
okay so when i got kicked off committees
i was like all right i'm brand new here
i want to learn how this place works um
and and here's what else you need to
understand if you're the minority party
nobody has no one in the minority party
has control on committees the majority
party has control on committees so if
democrats are in control they're
controlling the committees and they
control what bills are actually voted on
republicans have no choice we can't put
a bill to the floor unless we have 218
signatures to pull it out and we don't
have 218. so being in the minority
committees are pointless for us so i got
kicked off committees and i was like
okay big deal so i go sit on the house
floor just sitting there watching what's
happening because again i've never been
elected i've never held office i didn't
even go to the local gop meetings
because i thought they were silly and
stupid until now until now yeah and then
i go but here's here's what happens so
they were debating a bill back and forth
and they're debating it back and forth
and there was someone sitting in nancy
pelosi's seat the speaker's chair was
not nancy pelosi i don't know who it was
because they had a mask on and everybody
wears mask and i was like okay i don't
know who that is it was actually a man
so they're debating back and forth and
then the guy up there holding the gavel
in the speaker's chair
calls for
the vote by voice
so the democrats there was about five of
them on their side we there was about
five republicans on our side the
democrats it's their bill so they're
like yay and they're saying
yay they want to vote for it the
republicans on our side they're used to
getting defeated at this point because
we're into february and they're saying
they go nay without enthusiasm and then
all of a sudden the guy up there speaker
mask face he gavels it in
the bill has passed and i was like
i'm sitting here holding my voting card
in my hand and i'm like
i didn't vote and i was so confused so i
call one of the republican floor
staffers and i'm like what just happened
and he goes
ma'am
that's that's how we pass bills the bill
just passed and i was like i said what
are you talking about there's 435
members of congress there's like 10
people that said yay and nay i didn't
even vote i didn't say anything there's
a machine so here's what we have
on every other row there's a little
machine it looks like a credit card
machine and i have an id card it looks
like a driver's license as a member of
congress you put it in there and there's
three buttons you can push you can push
green for yes red for no and then
there's a yellow one that's for present
i don't know why you need present but
whatever
so i didn't get to vote no one else
voted it was not recorded so here's what
i found out
most of the bills in congress are passed
with a voice vote meaning millions and
millions and billions of american
taxpayer dollars
are passed that way remember when they
they had like that little ra the wagon
they carried the 5 000 pages in on do
you remember that what was that what was
that no one read the omnibus yeah yeah
omnibus
so mad about that ian went off he was
saying they should go to yeah yeah that
should be
i mean what come on
we elect someone to read the bills and
to decide if they're good or not that's
their job oh my goodness you i i agree
with you we should read the bills
because i can tell you there's horrible
things in them isn't it crazy that
you're saying 25 million for butterflies
i love butterflies but do i want to
spend what about 25 million dollars for
desert fish well what about desert fish
10 million dollars for pakistani gender
studies programs oh so important
pakistanis don't know what gender they
are how many genders do pakistanis have
why are american taxes
and speed votes for sri lanka i remember
that one too off the top of my head but
i don't i don't believe i don't believe
in many laws but i definitely believe in
the law that congressmen and women
should read the bill before they vote on
it i also believe in term limits and on
mandatory drug testing of members of
congress where do you stand on those all
those three issues okay wait i gotta
tell you one more thing hold on hold on
libertarian luke
as long as the government creates laws
to govern itself fine otherwise stay out
of my business i think people should be
allowed to do psychedelics yeah drugs
yeah yeah but but a lot of the you know
the i get your representatives are not
at work though because then believe me
they're not reading the bills
trust me if you would find out what the
politicians are really up to especially
when they're flying on those airplanes
and hanging on those islands and hanging
out with mr epstein you would want to
know exactly what they're doing and i
wouldn't want mandatory drug testing for
all of them because
there's some funny business to say the
least that is you don't want somebody on
drugs making a chili cheese dog
whatever i don't care about that let
them let them have more drugs if they're
making my chili cheese like i don't
they're probably gonna make it better
that is a good point though if the
government law is on the government
actors themselves they have to be
they have to be enforced by themselves
too so if there's regulations and
restrictions on small business they have
to abide by those same laws in their
private lives so i i think that would be
absolutely fair and would lead to people
of course not passing more more bull
crap so so three issues mandatory direct
testing turn limits and making sure that
people read every uh word of the bill
that they pass where do you think about
those three really quickly all right i
definitely don't think anyone should be
on drugs or drinking when they're at
work i just i'm i as an employer i would
be very upset if my employees were
drinking or on drugs it's dangerous but
just government employees well of course
just government guys so i'm employed by
my district and so i my goodness
what a horrible person i would be if i
was at work on drugs or drinking
they would fire me they should fire me
that's what i that's how i view that um
what was your other one mandatory term
limits me okay so you know who the
problem is who
the staff mm-hmm the staff never leaves
guess what
so i'm going to go into this a little
bit when i became a member of congress i
was given so here's how it works you
guys every member of congress is
allotted a certain amount of money per
year
so for my district my allotment is 1.4
million dollars with 1.4 million dollars
i have to hire my staff i have to pay
for district offices it's like a mini
business each member of congress is like
a mini business and you have to stay
within those bounds if i spend more than
that guess what i have to pay for it out
of my campaign funds so that's a big
no-no right so 1.4 million dollars but
here's the deal so when i went to
washington and i had to hire staff i'm
like who do i hire well guess what
there's a whole bunch of people that
there was the president trump just left
office there's a bunch of people looking
for jobs the staff in washington never
leaves that's the deep state i would
hire the homeless people in washington
dc if i was a congress maybe like come
off the streets don't even take a shower
just come on in personally myself
there's a guy named perspective brick
for dictator he rides around and and
yeah but anyways vermin supreme yes
he would be my chief of staff
so he's uh he's a satirical candidate
who has a boot on his head oh i haven't
seen him i went i went to a crazy
festival with him one year he's wild but
really interesting and a great guy so we
talk about the administrative state
being like the head of the fbi j edgar
hoover 40 years at the head of the fbi
administrative state all the way deep
state whatever and so you're saying that
the actual staff congressional staff is
also part of that administrative state
like they're just oh my gosh yeah and
they'll go from working in a democrat
office to work in a republican office
it's a job so let me let me clarify it's
a job turn limits for everyone including
the bureaucracy well so here's some
other things so let's say every
um i think the term i signed the term
limits pledge by the way
but i don't want to term limit myself
unless everyone else is term limited
because guess what that is oh yeah that
would be like leaving and then leaving
all the bad people in there so that
doesn't make sense um but if you
so here's something ten thousand hour
rule has any has anyone ever heard of
that ten thousand hours
something if you do something ten
thousand hours
oh my gosh you're an expert um so if i
played that guitar behind you for 10 000
hours i'm should be pretty good
yeah i would hope so um but anyways so
if you
if you're there for only six years or
for i think senators 12 years
you by the time you become an expert you
leave
and so i don't really know that all the
problems can be solved i know this i
want the good people to stay in and
fight and fix the problems so the term
limit the term limit issue is really
interesting if you only term limit the
members and of congress and the senators
but you never term limit the staff
and the changes there then essentially
you're not solving any problems yeah
that's why i say term limit uh all of
them i think it's rotten to the core and
i think the more we have new people in
there the less government does and that
to me
any kind of expert in government i don't
like because they're doing more
government stuff but that's my own
personal opinion and we could agree to
disagree with that
change yeah and nyokon wars that of
course don't produce anything and
destroy american uh soldiers lives
destroy our economy and absolutely just
fill the bank roles for multinational
corporations like halliburton that are
able to make too much money lockheed
martin all of them are just absolutely
controlling a lot of our policy that
also just quite benefits them at the
same time it's crazy what's happening in
washington dc i say fire all of them
myself but that's just my personal
perspective and opinion
i'm telling people vote in the primaries
oh primaries are where it's at
get rid of all the neocons the
establishments not the general it i mean
generals are important the primaries are
it the primary is the place where um if
it's a republican district they really
can pick a conservative versus a
moderate there's that opportunity in the
primary if it's a democrat district they
can pick a progressive versus a more
moderate democrat primaries are the most
important place to vote then you got to
get them across the line in the general
primaries are everything um but i want
to talk about uh roll calling votes so
back to that story you guys
when i found out that they could pass
bills by voice i also learned floor
procedure so it's like it's like games
right there's rules on each of us what
we can do so the next time the bill came
up and they were debating the bill back
and forth and i was really paying
attention this time and i had my lovely
little book in my lap that i had the
rules
they the speaker up there speaker mask
face is what i call them because i
didn't know who it was
he he asked for the vote the voice vote
and this time so the democrats are like
yay and the republicans over here nay
because they're used to losing
and right as
speaker mask face is about to say to
gavel it in announce the bill has passed
the rule is as a member of congress and
any of us can do it you have to get to
the microphone right then and you have
to say
madam speaker i asked for the recorded
vote and i did call him madam speaker
because gender doesn't count according
to our rules sorry anyone
but i did say that i said madam speaker
i asked for the recorded vote so here's
what happened
it was like uh
just a complete change
when i ask for that that means at that
moment they have to call all 435 members
of congress no matter where they are
to come down and vote on that bill and
everyone is on record that means you can
look up how your member your
representative voted you can look up
your member your representative you can
look up your member people can look me
up and go did she vote for that or did
she vote no for that what did what did
they do what did what did aoc vote what
did dan crenshaw vote what did eric
swalwell what did bang bang tell eric
swalwell to vote you know they can do
all this stuff so here's the here's the
deal recorded votes are so important so
i committed myself to that and i kept on
asking for recorded votes and i kept on
asking for recorded votes and i pissed
everybody off i'm talking about royally
good here's what happened so every time
they got called they got called out of
their uh
committee meeting they got called out of
their lunch with lobbyists they got
called out of their fundraising calls
that they were sitting there begging for
money
they had to wake jerry nadler up from
his nap i mean it was unbelievable
everybody had to come in and vote what
else did it do
it messed up the schedule nancy was very
upset because they had a whole schedule
they were bills were flying through and
all of a sudden they weren't flying
through anymore
cory bush's bill i defeated her bill it
was really important her bill actually
passed by voice until i asked for the
reported votes which bill which bill was
it it would have allowed
felons in prison to vote oh wow that's
what her bill did
so it won by the voice but then when you
double checked it they were like oh we
made a mistake
when i asked for the recorded votes even
democrats voted against her wow we had
318 i believe it was 318 no votes on
cory bush's bill to allow felons in
prison to vote wow so when people say
marjorie taylor green has not been
effective in congress i'm going to tell
you something right now i've got stories
for days i will argue i've been one of
the most effective members of congress
because i have put and led the effort to
put the entire united states congress on
record so that democrats can look up
their representative and say how did my
democrat that i voted for vote
republicans how did my republican
representative vote i think this is
extremely important for everyone across
the country to know the job performance
of their representative the
establishment can't be happy with you oh
no i got in trouble with republicans too
as a matter of fact i got chewed
out
i mean chewed out you wanna know why
marjorie
people don't want to be on record no no
meaning they don't want their
constituents to know how they voted
i want that person on record saying that
yeah that's dirty can you say who it was
i'm not forcing you to but virginia fox
dangerous that that's
all that should be on record i i've
gotten to the point where i tell it all
you want to know why because i think
it's important because the way they have
treated me no one defended me
no one defended me this is i you saw me
get kicked off committees
then there were 11 republicans that
voted with democrats kicked me off
committees because of things they didn't
like that i said on facebook years
before i ever ran for congress or became
a member of congress it didn't matter
what i was when i walked in and swore in
or who i was didn't matter my great life
record my career the fact that i've
never been arrested i've never done
drugs that i've raised three amazing
children none of that mattered to them
it was we don't like a few things on
facebook what maybe she liked or this
she possibly said or or anything
they kicked me off for that and then no
one defended me yep no one defended me
and no one helped me that really really
pissed me off because ilhan omar of
course you know has said things that
have been condemned across the board and
they defend her
when when i refer to what she says as
crop dusting anti-semitism meaning like
the plane gets real close to the ground
she wasn't overtly saying it but
sometimes it does she kept saying things
that were getting a lot of people to say
like hey like when you say it one time
we're kind of like maybe there's a
mistake maybe you don't understand but
when you do it over and over again
now regardless of whether anyone's
really offended what bothers me is the
democrats would condemn you but defend
her there's no principle it's just it's
just political it's it's political war
yeah it's political whatever they can do
to hurt you and defend their side when
you were saying that the majority uh
gets the the committees basically is
that like because if there's a majority
of democrats minority republicans they
go to every committee and put that ratio
on every committee so there are ratios
and that's a great question so it's a
majority controlled body that's what how
congress works and so whoever the
majority party is and right now it's the
democrats they get to control each
committee meaning that the democrat
chairman the chairman of each committee
will be a democrat and that chairman of
each committee say chairman of judiciary
which is jerry nadler he will control
which um
investigations they do he gets to
control which bills judiciary committee
which bills come out of judiciary and
which bills go to the floor that we all
vote on and so a majority controlled
congress means that the democrats or
republicans whoever's the majority
controls from all the committees it's
kind of like a party yeah like a like
like they just say well this we have it
now this is our unit party but like
maybe if it was 60 40 and like the
republicans chaired 40 of the committees
and the democrats chair the other 60
that might not work no and they've tried
that before i don't know how it works is
no whoever is the majority controlling
party they control all the committees
well not even split them up let's talk
about uh the midterms are coming up 2022
they're saying there's going to be a red
tsunami we've got what now 25 democrats
i think we're at have announced they're
going to be retiring yep what do you
think is going to happen
i don't know honestly i i don't know if
here i'm going to tell you here's why i
don't know if there's going to be a red
tsunami i definitely think that
republicans will win the majority all
the indicators are there joe biden's
polling his numbers are awful
people are very upset about the
inflation crime the border people are
freaked out over things like um uh
vaccine mandates masking kids in school
the long shutdowns will there be more
the nonstop talk of the never ending
coveted 19. we had never ending wars now
we have never ending covet 19. where is
that going authoritarian control these
are issues people really care about
other things people care about is
election integrity that issue has never
gone away it's still really important
people still talk about it
people also care about the pre-trial
january 6th defendants
i will never defend the riot at the
capitol i won't defend what those people
did but i will talk i have been in that
jail push my way in there produced a
report for everyone to read because i
thought oh my gosh this is such a
perverse uh
action to our justice system it's
terrible but here's the deal for the
2022 midterms
i'll i'll tell you what i did some
polling
through town halls i've done it twice
and on my town hall
we called
republican voters they are general
voters primary voters so that's who was
on my call
and i asked them how do you feel about
are you going to be voting in the 2022
elections uh press one if you feel your
vote is safe and you feel good about
georgia's new election laws press two if
um no you don't feel good about the law
you don't think your vote is safe
press three if you will not vote
and and press four if you're unsure
here's what really shook my confidence
in what is going to happen in the 2022
midterms
because it's been talked about elections
have been talked about so much
on both times
four percent the first time said they
will not vote
the second time five percent said they
will not vote wow let me tell you why
that's
terrifying
because in georgia here's in georgia
in 2018
stacey abrams almost became governor
brian kemp barely won
and if you take four percent of his
total votes
that and they don't vote stacey abrams
would have won in 2018.
so the reason why i say i don't know if
it's going to be a tsunami or not
because i don't i travel the country
i've been i've been all over the country
this past year because i wanted to get
out and and bring a message of
positivity to people
those people i talk to are everywhere i
think there's that percentage existing
especially in states where they really
feel like their votes were stolen that
percentage is everywhere and i don't
know how that's going to translate will
those people change their mind by the
time they get to the elections well a
lot of republicans i'll be honest with
you are seen as kind of wishy-washy
individuals who kind of sit on their
hands as the democrats kind of lead the
way and they kind of just sit there not
opposing anything of it there definitely
does seem to be a fracture within the
republican party uh on one side you have
kind of the ron paul freedom-oriented
individuals and on the other side you of
course have the mitt romney's who
believe in you know big money big power
where do you see
yourself on that kind of spectrum from
uh you know 100 being ron paul zero
being mitt romney and is there a way to
kind of heal this divide and give people
confidence in the republican party since
of course so many people feel let down
by them
that is a great question i'm nowhere
near mitt romney uh as far away probably
as possible um and ron paul is a hundred
so that's what would you get standards
that's my standard
he's a pretty cool guy
so
here's what i think i think there is
really there really is a civil war in
the gop i think there's one also uh in
the democrat party i'm i think it exists
there is an equal fight in both of them
here's where it is in the gop okay so
the liz cheney brand the adam kenzinger
brand i'm going to throw dan crenshaw
with them because that's who i think he
is um we're going to put mitt romney in
there we're going to put mitch mcconnell
in there and i could go through the list
but
that brand of the gop is a very small
percent of the voters the the wide base
of voters are conservative they're
they're definitely on my brand of
politics
they're definitely
more freedom caucus which is i'm a
member of the freedom caucus
they're definitely the small government
constitutionalist pro-freedom
pro-america voter that's who the
republican base is
now the big money donors like i was
talking about paul singer over at
twitter right that doesn't like me and
hates president trump i think he hates
me actually too oddly enough we're not
no longer on twitter um
those are those are the type of big
donors there are
for the gop so it's a little bit messy
right
now you have in the democrat party so
what it bernie sanders i'm i'm going to
argue that bernie sanders okay we're on
youtube i don't don't freak out over
election stuff
but i think bernie sanders probably beat
hillary clinton right
i mean that's what's been talked about
you've got a lot of people love uh the
progressives they love the the climate i
think it's like a climate religion i i
know there's climate change i don't
argue there's not climate change there
always has been climate change
throughout the history of the earth i
just don't think humans are causing it
but here's the thing so the dnc the
democrat party they have their brand too
they fight back and forth too their base
is growing more and more to the
progressive side that's where their high
volume of growth is but just really
quick zero to a hundred on the liberty
scale what's your number i don't know
zero to a hundred tell them a hundred
freedom liberty personality it's a
nebulous question
i wanna know i don't know i don't know
what 99 means or 98 or 97. your
interpretation obviously it's a loose
one i i think i'm prettier than ron paul
but i think it's not it's not a pretty
scale it's a freedom skill freedom you
know liberty personal responsibility
definitely very pro freedom very very
pro liberty you know what the the
climate change stuff comes up so much
but i feel like as we produce carbon we
can recollect the carbon and turn it
into stuff like graphene and reuse it as
a material it's a valuable resource and
i want the conversation to go that
direction as opposed to oh we're afraid
we want to stop producing carb like
you're always going to be pumping carbon
out there and reusing it
you know i think there's so many people
that that come and talk about carbon
with sincerity right
but then here's the elites and i'm going
to go back to the corporate communist
let's talk about carbon tax credits and
let's talk about how all that is is
really buying forgiveness right
so the the whole carbon discussion is
going to boil down into government
regulation it's going to boil down into
taxes because that's where the
government solution is it's not really
so like carbon tax credits for instance
if i if i'm a big company and i produce
a lot of carbon i can buy a bunch of
carbon tax credits and get forgiven for
my carbon output not that i actually
reduce my carbon or learn how to capture
it or change it but i'm actually buying
forgiveness so so you see the the
solutions for people that really are
into the climate change stuff or any of
the carbon things the actual government
solutions are really the opposite of
what i think those people genuinely
believe do you think that the government
would end up building like large-scale
carbon recapture technologies or is that
they just leave it to the point no i
think they want to tax tax you okay i
think they want to tax businesses and
they want to make you pay for your
carbon output and and not really ian you
don't want to find out who the carbine
is that they're trying to reduce you
don't want to i i think it's just
selling us out of china all of it i do
too the heavier regulations make it
easier for chinese industry to sell to
us the free trade raising look i i don't
want people in this country to be
working on on slave you know poverty
wages
but this idea of raising the minimum
wage at the same time raising the
corporate tax and at the same time
allowing free trade for these companies
all you're doing is saying we're going
to increase the barriers for your
company in america and decrease the
barriers for your company operating out
of china which is just extracting more
and more from this country if we go down
that path there's going to be nothing
for the working class no there's going
to be nothing because the working class
loses president xi is not doesn't care
about reducing his carbon output he's
actually increased it you want to know
why because he can't produce enough
power with solar and uh wind
unfortunately that technology isn't
there yet it just it just isn't so what
did president xi do this year he
increased his his coal production to
increase electricity why because america
is sending them more business because
joe biden is all about globalism and
he's pro-china this is a serious problem
and we have that that nice young woman
greta tunberg who complains about europe
and the united states and completely
ignores for the most part india and
china
so
that to me
you're not solving the problem when
you're blaming the one country that has
paper straw we're not the one country
but when i was i was at the airport in
texas and the lady walks up to me with a
with a with an iced tea and a paper
straw and she looks at me and she goes
i'm sorry
i'm not even getting like true stories
god bless her bless her heart for saying
i'm sorry nobody likes a paper straw
dissolves and you're like
but most importantly it's also a lot of
the people who are creating the problems
a lot of billionaires that are creating
the solution which means more money kind
of given to them which is such a strange
idea it just absolutely doesn't make
sense uh but but i also they pay all the
lobbyists of course and obviously they
have favors and they get favorable
policy i had kind of one more question
that i kind of had on my list that i
wanted to ask you since we see the
corporate media kind of label you as you
know crazy what would you say is your
craziest belief that you personally
believe in my craziest belief yes
um let's see
sorry i like to do oddball questions and
ask things
others would think my craziest belief um
gosh that's tough i would probably say
that i really just don't believe it's
people's fault that the climate changes
i i mean the climate's been changing
since the beginning of time if you look
at the ice ages no none of the people
back in the ice ages paid a bunch of
taxes to melt the ice so it's absolutely
ridiculous to say that government
solutions uh paying more taxes to try to
figure out how to reduce carbon what on
paper really not in reality is going to
do anything about climate change the
climate just changes i mean here's the
we live on a ball
it is literally a ball that spins
and this spinning ball earth rotates
around a flaming ball which is the sun
and at the same time this is moving
throughout our uh galaxy which is moving
throughout the universe
i i'm going to argue yeah with
gravitational pull and all of that of
course our climate's going to change
yeah we um there's evidence we're still
in the ice age twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago at the end of the
younger dryas a comet hit earth and
melted the glaciers in the north wiped
out all the megafauna on north america
flattened what we have now the planes
caused the sahara all that ocean sand
got smushed up annihilated atlantis
reset humanity but we're still in that
ice age it's just preemptively melted a
bunch of it and now it's we're easing
our way out of the ice age which is why
things have been getting warmer but
nobody paid taxes to make that happen
that we know of we don't know what kind
of technology they had if they had
wireless electricity i i'm open to it
wait maybe they have microchips and they
have the original ids tattoos yeah
something like that so we're gonna go to
super chats but we are going to have a
special members only not so
family-friendly you know totally
uncensored conversation that will be up
at around 11 p.m over at timcast.com so
make sure you go to timcast.com sign up
become a member because you won't want
to miss that but for now we're going to
read your super chat so smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and we had
one super chat just recently normally i
go to the beginning but i gotta read
this one because it exemplifies a point
i was making before
we have rockslide says marjorie i've
never actually heard from you just what
people have said about you listening to
you now you sound very competent and
grounded like a real person not a fake
politician respect
oh thank you very much i really
appreciate it thank you so this is
uh um we're talking to steve bannon
about something similar yeah because
after we had him on the show the second
time we had messages from people saying
i had only heard about him from
mainstream media and i didn't actually
know you know who he was or what he
sounded like and they were like upon
hearing him actually speak you're like
oh he's kind of like a normal guy and
his views aren't that crazy at all no
steve is great i love steve bannon
you're right perceptions are wrong and i
think they go both ways so it's good to
talk about it that's why i think it's i
want to highlight this because what they
say about you is very different from
what you say
exactly yeah
fake news or something like that fake
news
fake news all right we got a super chat
i can't read your name because youtube
blocks us but it says mtg and then it's
the emoji with the heart eyes as usa usa
usa and a thumbs up
usa yeah
all right let's try and grab some super
chats just some of these are uh about
marjorie did you ever play uh magic the
gathering i i haven't but i've i've come
i've seen it in mtg yeah magic the
gathering i don't even know what it is
thanks for repping it's an awesome card
game oh is it collectible card game oh
man they should have a card for me
so when uh
my voice is a little raspy you can
notice this morning i was like i i
didn't want to do my morning show
because i was like this is going to be
an important show to have this
conversation so i said i'd rather just
rest but people were trying to guess who
we were going to have on because we i
didn't we didn't announce or anything
and so we do have super chats where
they're like yes i was right it's
margery
did they bet money on it no no no money
just they're posting comments uh here's
one clef the misfit says congressman
greene please please please go on
michael malus's podcast you're welcome
so are you familiar with michael malus
we're huge fans of his we're good
friends
he is i don't know how to describe
michael miller a writer chaos agent
these are well the safest way to
describe it he's a writer he's an
anarchist writer on north korea
uh yeah he was born in russia or ukraine
ukraine
uh so very anti-communist wow yeah cool
i should do it yeah you should well you
should look into him yeah sure you know
anti-communist anarchist yes
anti-communists
i think that's a good way he wrote yeah
yeah yeah but he's not like a left aunty
for anything like that
well i'm all for conversation yes yeah
he's really great actually he
understands that you got to make people
laugh if you're going to tell him the
truth
he's really smart all right psyllium
says marjorie taylor green makes me
proud i'm from georgia please raffle
another ar protect our rights oh
definitely oh love that thank you you
raffled off in ar oh yeah listen listen
ar-15 i think is the best uh
best weapon for women i seriously do
it's easy to hold it's easy to shoot i
know people think it's scary it's not
it's actually is such a great gun um and
i i think it's the best uh home defense
weapon for women the reason it's so
popular yes all right here's a little
spicy one so kind of kind of spicy one
ctk says marjorie why do you think there
are so many traitors in the republican
party democrats stick together but we
have useless romney murkowski et cetera
ooh uh i totally agree i think here's
our problem in the republican party um
it's that civil war that i was talking
about we don't have our identity uh and
then
that that leads to failure right um that
leads people to think that there's
traitors i i think mitch mcconnell is a
traitor to our party i i totally agree i
don't know why that's so i think it's
the way it's set up um the they never
reward the conservatives the fighters
they don't reward people like me um
people like
jim jordan people like matt gates louie
gohmert paul gosar we're usually cast to
the side
it's always the more the moderates it's
the uniparty the uniparty is real in
washington dc it's the the republicans
like john catko that's really a democrat
but for some reason he's a republican um
and then they believe in the majority
makers i think the majority makers is
such a failure i'm one of those that i
think that you give people something to
vote for
if if you are a strong fighting
conservative you're going to bring we're
going to bring more voters to vote
republican
than we ever could because there's a lot
of people sitting to the sideline going
you know these people never do anything
they never accomplish anything they
never do what they're going to say so
why should i even bother voting for them
so i think it's
my belief for the republican party is to
actually do and say what we're what
we're about but do it and give people
something to vote for and i think the
fact that we don't do that and we failed
at that that's why there's the uniparty
and that's why those are the ones that
hold all the strong leaderships a couple
people we got uh keith and devon have
both said that corporate communism is
the dictionary definition of fascism
basically the the merger between
corporation and state for lucrative
events however the reason i didn't bring
that i normally bring that up but the
reason i didn't bring it up in
how you how you phrased it is that
fascism is also traditionalist
so when you say corporate communism it
is the lucrative merger of corporation
and state but they're progressive
yeah we could say that now here's
another so words matter right
so the democrats and the media have
spent arguably five years framing
republicans as fascists so if i sit
there and argue fascism fascism fascism
it's gonna be no you're a fascist no
you're a fascist and there's no
understanding of what it actually means
that's why i call it corporate communism
because the perfect example is joe biden
pushing the vaccine mandates through the
corporations onto their employers i mean
they're employees so if you're a company
that has 100 or more employees
you are pushing the government's rule
to your employees so that government
rule is coming through the corporation
that's a classic example and so it's the
the merging uh of that power structure
there with the corporations and the
government
all right medic says tim asked marjorie
if she would support shane hazel for
governor brian kemp and vernon jones are
just rhinos republicans won't save
georgia from stacy abrams and the
democrats look into the libertarian
party mises caucus are you familiar with
the mises caucus libertarian party
i i'm not as familiar i know who shane
hazel is um he was he ran as a
republican before i believe and then he
ran as a libertarian for senate and now
he's a libertarian
for governor i think our our real
problem is i think our republican party
has failed libertarians by ostracizing
them and pushing them out i really think
that people like shane hazel where did
he start he started as a republican so
that's why i urged republicans in
georgia that they need to listen to
shane hazel and listen to libertarian
views um because that way
they're not ostracizing them and
creating what's gonna happen though is
this is gonna be a real risk for stacey
abrams to be governor of georgia oh yeah
all right let's see
ernie baio says wish we had more reps
like mtg my question is have you seen
the comments by ted cruz calling the
riot on january 6th a terror attack if
so do you fear it'll cause more people
to lose faith in the gop not that i have
any
yeah i don't often times don't have any
myself
i was very upset by those comments
because no one has been charged with
terrorism uh and i'm not sure why ted
cruz felt compelled to say that i talked
about it with steve bannon we were both
very upset about it um it was it was the
wrong thing for him to say no one has
been charged for terrorism no one has
been charged for insurrection
it was a riot the same way there were
antifa and blm rioters and they were
charged and over 90 of their charges
have been dropped but yet
none of these people's charges have been
dropped and then there's there's quite a
few of them rotting in jail
they spent christmas time in solitary
confinement their their medical uh
they're not getting medical treatment
it's it's unbelievable they can't get
they can't shave they can't get haircuts
uh they can't get chapel in the dc jail
they can't get communion
absolutely horrible what's happening to
them
but no ted cruz was extremely wrong when
he when he called them terrorists are
there other video and or interviews with
these prisoners
no we couldn't do that on when i went in
the jail we we couldn't couldn't video
or or interview um
i taught we talked to them uh we talked
to them a lot that's that's where they
told me about these things they've also
tried to file reports their attorneys
do everything they can to get the
information out their families do
everything they can to get the
information out you know what the real
problem is it's because the january 6
rioters have been
cast in such a horrible light as
insurrectionist no one will help them
i'm one of the few republican members of
congress one of the few members of
congress period that will actually care
about what's happening to these people
in jail um
it's it's terrible people are scared to
help them people are scared to talk
about them but it's an extremely
important issue to so many americans
because they look at that and go this is
a two-tiered justice system
how can these people be treated one way
and then other people that rioted for
their cause be have their charges
dropped and treated completely different
it's terrifying when we see our
government doing that
all right laura mora says hey tim mtg
says she doesn't take lobbyist money ask
her about her pfizer stock
oh yes i just found out recently when
the media reported that i owned pfizer
so i signed an agreement with my
financial advisor he has full authority
to to handle all of that because i
wanted to make sure hey i don't want to
be involved in this
so it gets reported that i own stock in
pfizer and johnson and johnson so i call
up my financial advisor i'm like is this
true do i own stock in pfizer well no
how they were reporting it was vaccine
vaccine companies yeah okay
so if i'm first off i'm in the minority
minority party and i'm not on committees
i can assure everyone i am not privy to
any kind of insider information and i
have no control over it i'm also against
vaccine mandates i'm not vaccinated
myself so if that was anything i'm not
helping myself out
um
here's here's what's really interesting
pfizer makes many kind of drugs my dad
passed away this year from cancer
yes i want him to have i wanted him i
wanted him to be able to live i wanted
him to have medications for cancer
another thing i can say is there's a lot
of guys that suffer with low t and they
love viagra viagra also is made by
pfizer and it you know it helps heart
conditions it even has helped
alzheimer's because it increases
circulation so owning stock in pfizer
i've owned it since 2017 before i became
a member of congress and i don't think
that makes me a bad person johnson and
johnson they make
baby oil baby powder they make so many
things they're both american companies
and i think too um
that when a few a bunch of members of
congress were criticized for this people
should realize that often
people sign this to somebody else yeah
you assign someone and do it for you yes
i
and then so but i i don't like the idea
that uh members of like nancy pelosi's
stocks you know she's now if anybody
wants to do her stock picks i say follow
that lady because she's made a lot of
money over the years it's incredible i i
don't i think all of that's wrong though
i really do but yeah i don't know what i
honestly have no idea what i own i gave
that full authority over to someone else
right on all right devin ray says love
ian and rarely agree with him however
his statement it should be a federal
offense to sign a bill they haven't read
was the best thing ever no i agree can i
completely agree when i when the omnibus
thing came in and they wheeled it in
that cart i was just like dude yeah that
that is like taking a sledgehammer to
what little little optimism i have left
in the withered husk of my of my
politics yeah my my lovely staff over
here has read pretty much all the bills
um they print them and they have to
do the hole punchers and put them in the
giant binders i mean i i can't even i
don't even know how many binders we've
created with all the bills
hours and hours of reading and you can't
even get through over 2 500 pages in the
amount of time that we're supposed to
that's the thing it's insane to expect
you to read that exactly
like what how many bills come through in
a week like how many pages of bills oh
my gosh
no one could if we didn't sleep we
literally never slept we still couldn't
read it so it's a that's a
malfunctioning system
it is a failure congress is a failure i
say it over and over it's complete
failure the whole thing top down bottom
up it is a failure it worked 200 years
ago and now it's too big
too few people doing so many problems
and we have too many government agencies
that just keep on going and we keep on
funding them even though they're they
don't do anything anymore we we pass
bills that no one reads no one reads
them and people then they find out later
like oh my gosh i voted for that yeah
you dummy you couldn't read it we didn't
read it but we had to you you we voice
voted it like why
it is
every i i have been screaming from the
rooftops being kicked off committees was
the best thing that ever happened to me
because i could find out how
dysfunctional congress is and and i try
to tell everyone about it i want every
american to know how bad congress is
failing americans
if the republicans win back the house
this year would you support donald trump
as speaker
oh
i you know what i think it was bannon
who brought that up
matt gates has also been pushing that
one
i i think it would be amazing
i but i don't think that he would do it
but
so i only support ideas that i think
will actually happen until i hear uh uh
president trump say that he would do it
then that's when i'll make a decision on
it but but that would be crazy i think
it'd be cool here's the important one i
think for all of us here in the room gop
gamer says would you be willing to push
for the repealing of the 1934 national
firearms act
oh wow
that's impressive look i am as pro
second amendment as they come i i
absolutely support everything for gun
rights so would you would you so are are
you familiar with the like with what the
nfa does specifically
i don't mean to put you on the spot it's
just that there's like there's a lot of
nuance about that i'm not completely
familiar with i think i don't have all
the details either so it's hard for me
to say it's basically where some like
they banned
fully automatic machine guns oh i think
no fully automatic machine guns are so
cool
why can't i own one i should be able to
own one so uh
i'm not it's hard for me to get into the
nitty-gritty of exactly everything it
does i don't want to pretend to be a
firearms expert but silencers uh
i think they're great i they're they
damage your suppressors yes suppressors
they
you know i care about my hearing yeah so
i'm completely in favor of repealing the
nfa and uh i think it was michael malus
brought this up because we were such big
fans we referenced him over and over and
over again but he made he made this
point that you know when democrats get
in congress they say we are going to
force everyone to do this thing like
universal health care you've got bernie
sanders saying abolish private health
care and then just have you know a
single government system oh my gosh the
republicans get in and say no wait don't
but the republicans in my view need to
go in and say instead of just saying no
gun control we're going to say repeal
gun control yeah see that's the issue so
it's constantly creating new laws and
passing them that's the problem what we
need to do is we need to get rid of the
old things no i i don't know why we why
do you we continue to grow the
government and grow the government and
grow the government it's just creating
more bureaucracy when we get rid of the
things that don't matter anymore like
sunset clauses
sunset clauses would that make too much
workload for people in congress to
constantly have to go over laws that are
coming up for dispersal not enough they
need as much work as they can so they
don't do nothing sorry we could
outsource the workload of american
citizens i have hardly had any time
doing nothing but i know what you mean
no i think sunset clauses are great i i
think
here's how i feel i believe the
government serves the people
the taxpayers pay for everything they
pay for the buildings they pay for my
salary they pay the light bill
i fully believe that everything that's
done there should serve the people to
the best of its ability if that means we
have to work harder and and work at
sunset clauses and then and say okay
maybe we need to bring this back
whatever we need to do i think it's
important that we do it
so uh young asks you mentioned that blue
jeans company and they want to know what
the name is so they can support them
oh i wish i wish that i i'd rather not
do that because anything i say there's
really nasty people on the left that
will attack things that i promote and i
i think it's terrible so things that i
love and value and cherish i don't i
don't want to talk about and say the
name all right this one we'll get a
little spicy raymond g stanley jr says
ms marjorie thank you for coming you
look fit do you actively advocate for
the health of our youth which will help
them succeed too many fatties
solid
i i am a huge supporter for help i think
that it's so important i've been an
athlete my entire life um i've always
competed i i did a lot of running races
cycling races triathlons then i got into
some crazy cult fitness thing called
crossfit oh yeah um even open a crossfit
gym competed on a world level
in 2015 i was 47th in the world
in my division in crossfit um i
absolutely love it i loved weightlifting
i started a crossfit kids program at my
gym
my kids have always played sports
i i think that fitness is important no
matter what level you are i think it's
important to exercise and find something
you love to do healthy eating is
extremely important but i will give a
major plug for chocolate chip cookies
and ice cream because i love them there
are there are just several more super
chats asking you to look into
repealing or or taking action against
the national firearms act yeah so i i
got in popular everybody wants a cool
automatic machine gun well yeah so this
i i think i i i was reading the history
of it now surprised it passed in the
first place because basically back in
the old gangster days they had the tommy
gun and so the federal government was
like let's just we can't ban guns but we
can put a tax on it make it really hard
for people to buy yeah they want to tax
everything i mean i so i have a banned
the atf bill i don't know if people
would you want to abolish the atf yes i
like that idea that's a great idea
actually
abolish the atf's you know it's like why
are we why are we uh you know
taxing tobacco that's like what's the
point so you know the atf is is
completely pointless in my mind we have
other government agencies that do the
work that that is valuable that the atf
does but so why why do we have you know
a double double agencies again that's
just waste government waste um so yes we
need to completely abolish the atf
and i i wrote a bill to do that oh wow
well take a look at the nfa because i
think once you dig into it and look at
it you'll probably end up coming out and
being like yeah we're going to get rid
of that probably i'm very very
anti-regulation so so right now if you
want to go to a gun shop and buy a
suppressor for instance which makes the
weapon safer in a lot of ways for
everybody like you said it protects your
hearing yeah and especially if you're if
you're engaging in defense of your home
it could take you up to a year which is
awful
i mean i think that's criminal of the
government to do that to people i think
hearing is extremely important these are
these are laws passed by people that
don't know anything about yeah they they
don't they've never used them and they
want to call them weapons of war um and
they want to make them into hollywood
killing machines i think suppressors are
fantastic yeah and it's not just that
it's um uh short barreled rifles like
sort of like certain lengths i think
it's like leave me alone with my length
of my gun
i'm barely five foot three i i don't see
anything wrong with a short barrel
we'll take a look at the nfa all right
so uh emo says will marjorie taylor
green read anatomy of the state by
murray rothbard
that's a good book marjorie taylor green
has never heard of that book oh my god
these are the these are the libertarians
and the anarchists wanting you to read
their their
stuff okay it's a great book but it is
it is good it is good it is good what's
the 10 seconds dog buddy over here he
likes it well i think i think no
government
i think it's fairly obvious a lot of
people that in a lot of ways
libertarians and conservatives overlap
on a lot of issues oh i think it's great
to to understand
all the different ideas i'm not opposed
at all
ooh some a lot of people are mad at ted
cruz over calling january 6 a terror
attack yep i'm in agreement it's not a
terror attack no one declared it that no
one's been charged with terrorism
devin says please ask marjorie if she
would talk to trump about coming on the
show that would be amazing just
shamelessly trying to get you to get
traffic
i think president trump should come on
your show well we actually we have
talked because we've had um several
people on the show who know trump you
know very personally and
everyone kind of agrees they're like
you'd have to bring the show to him and
it would certainly not be a long-form
two-hour thing except for me i don't
agree it's gonna be fun
i think it would be a blast although i
don't know if you'd still be on youtube
yeah yep
yep that's true that is true i mean i
don't know if it was trump i might just
say we're this is a man
well it's one of the most one of the
most significant if not the most
significant figure in our generation oh
he's amazing and well i'll tell you
about president trump is everything that
you see
um of him he's the same person uh behind
closed doors he's just very much a real
guy
why he's he's always been so appealing
to me is because i own a construction
company and that's what he did he's a
regular guy he talks like regular men um
you know i support him and and supported
him before i always did not because i
was looking for some perfect politician
i was looking for a real person and
that's what's appealing and that's who
president trump is yeah
all right raymond again he asks marjorie
thank you for coming can we stop our
military from becoming woke weak opinion
on what's needed for our military to be
strong
uh we are going to have to
win and 22 we're going to win in 24 and
make some serious changes no i think
what's happening to the military is
devastating uh when you've got pr uh you
know putin of russia uh talking about
masculinity and making that really
important talking about gender being
male and female and rejecting all these
uh woke ideas uh but we've got the
american military we're paying for
transgender surgeries i mean how does
that even make sense uh forcing vaccine
mandates and no not allowing any
religious exemptions
which is forcing out people
that we really need in the military so
the woke problem in the military is not
going to end unfortunately anytime soon
and um the military should be really
just for the defense of our country but
unfortunately it's been politicized
extremely weak command at the moment
biden surrendered in afghanistan that's
a surrender that's a lo that's not a
withdrawal it's not a white peace he
surrendered we lost the war we were
winning it and in a moment he took out
air support and surrendered this i don't
think we were winning we would we were
dominating that country while our
military was there was just costing us
you know a psychosis basically but well
and he demoralized them he demoralized
them he pulled them out in such a uh
failure
and so i i it's tragedy really because
think about the how that made them feel
on the inside the veteran suicide rate
what will that be in the future because
of how they were demoralized and the
intelligence agencies were using it as a
way to kind of push heroin on the world
too so there's that in afghanistan yeah
the poppy fields pictures of us troops
guarding poppy fields well and really we
built remember the structure for the
rare earth mineral mines and handed them
over to china and then that goes back to
hunter biden's laptop uh
what's on that thing there's a lot on
there and they did business in china
hunter still owns
you know part of a company in china oh
like they were like we'll give you china
if you give us fill in the blank or
we'll give you afghanistan if you give
us
mineral mines and then we're going to
pass laws that force americans to drive
electric vehicles so that they are
automatically your customers love her
annika says i really didn't like marjory
taylor green because the media told me
she was a kook but after listening to
her have this convo i want to have a
cheeseburger with her too i vote for her
if i wasn't in california also love you
ian never changed love
the reason i want to i read that one and
the one before is that i'm sick of the
media lying about people yeah and just
like thank you and thank you to that
person that was really kind yeah and we
i would add a milkshake absolutely um i
think
i love i love it when people criticize
other people i love it when i get
criticized when it's real criticism
yeah it's constructive even
but even if it is mean even if someone's
like this person is the worst member of
congress because she believes in this
policy it's like well she does believe
in that policy and they don't like it
it's something called opponent processes
i was listening to jordan peterson
talking about in nature you have these
things called opponent processes where
if there's a motion you're trying to
move stably if you press against it it's
easier to stabilize and move at your own
pace but you need that
you know that that asserting pressure
challenge and and to have it banned off
of social media is a big problem we need
that
i agree
i agree you know how twitter fails too
it's only like 240 characters yeah how
hard it is to say what you're trying to
say in 240 characters and then you can't
edit and then i misspell things or
mistype it or autocorrect and i can't
fix it and then i get made fun of
because i misspelled something i'm like
man did you guys ever get it where you
land right on 240 characters oh yeah
i used to hit zero all the time
it's really freeing to be on these other
platforms where you can just have a
couple paragraphs yes go to getter go to
gab go to telegram go away go president
trump's new platform's coming soon you
guys i've heard i talked yes we talked
about that yesterday it's really soon
tony says people told me she was crazy
this lady just had abolished the atf it
might be in love hashtag a cab
you know you know a-cap means
all cops are we'll say bad
oh yeah yeah yeah the the actual
anarchists are going to be like i would
vote for that you know abolishing the
atf for sure
oh wait no the media told you people
you're not supposed to like me remember
remember your programming yes exactly
wow this is interesting uh timothy
williams says uh margery i thought you
were crazy because of what i heard and i
watch a lot of pool and crowder and
others but very down to earth and i
agree with a lot and that's that's a lot
of what we heard too that you know
they're like watch any of our interviews
and it's like calm straightforward
normal conversations
but your opinions go against the
establishment so the things that make it
out in the press are going to be the
worst possible framing the lies the
smears i'm just like look
you know uh i've talked about the things
you wrote on facebook in the past two
yeah and i've said basically what you
said if you didn't say it while you're
in congress i don't know why it's
relevant to congress and if you
apologize for it then we can all move on
and have real conversations about policy
but it seems like they you know if they
want to find a way
to keep people from hearing you
that's the problem we have in this
country that's right and and
it is because i challenge i challenge
everything and everybody i don't just
sit there and go along with okay my
republican conference says this this is
what we're going to do and yes yes yes
i'm not like that i will argue i mean
i'm openly arguing with dan crenshaw
right now and and i'm openly calling out
a mega donor a republican mega donor
that's in control of twitter he was able
to get jack dorsey out i mean i think
it's fair to say marjory taylor green is
not there to go along and get along but
at the same time i'm challenging
democrat ideas that i really disagree
with that hurt our entire country like
this insanity of forcing us to depend on
china to drive like what in the world
are we doing that is why they hate me
because they hate me considering how
much americans disapprove of congress
hearing that you you were forcing the
roll call votes and making all of them
do their job yeah i like that i'm sure a
lot of people were just laughing at home
oh my gosh
everybody was mad at me that's what
everybody needs to know both parties
were
ticked off at marjory taylor green yeah
it was yeah but it's fun we'll get one
more super chat in kj says marjorie what
can we do to encourage more ordinary
citizens to run for office it seems
conservatives are either too comfortable
or are afraid of being drowned by the
swamp oh gosh we should do a whole
podcast you want me to come back to a
podcast on that oh yeah
all about campaigns and how it works it
is the hardest thing it is so deep and
difficult anybody that truly is
conservative is going to get instantly
rejected the minute they walk in the
door you want to know why they hate you
they do they hate you they don't want
you in there and then the democrat party
is going to be the same way because they
want their candidates so it's very hard
to to get through um it's it's too much
to explain in just a short amount of
time i'm so sorry to that person but i
encourage gosh i encourage people to run
not necessarily you have to run for
congress or senate local local politics
is more important than anybody
understands school board city council
county commissioner yes primaries oh my
gosh primaries
go all in at a local level knock out a
rhino knock knockout we are going to
start recording we are going to start
recording the members only segment we
have limited time so i will just say
right now thanks for watching smash that
like button subscribe to the channel and
go to timcast.com the members only video
should be up around 11 or so p.m you can
follow the show tim castaire everywhere
you can follow me at tim cast basically
everywhere do you want to shout out
anything marjorie before we go oh um if
you want to support me mtgforamerica.com
that's my website i greatly appreciate
your support um like i said i totally am
supported by regular american small
dollar contributions or the best uh you
can't follow me on twitter i'm on getter
i'm on telegram i'm on gab look for the
verified accounts there's a ton of fake
ones and they probably say crazy things
that continue to make me look crazy but
thank you so much and this has been
awesome and i'm
so nice to meet you all y'all are the
best absolutely abolish the atf and i
have my own media organization on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
and i also have my own online safe space
slash secret society on luke uncensored
dot com hope to see some of you guys
there thanks for having me this was
great a boss to atf
hey follow me ian crossland.net i love
you thank you for coming marjorie thank
you oh thank you so much marjorie and
thank you guys all for tuning in i had a
blast i was enchanted listening to you i
was very much in the same boat as a lot
of our listeners i didn't know much
about you so glad i had a chance to talk
um you guys are welcome to follow me on
still on twitter for now
at sourpatchlids we will see you all
over at timcast.com in the member
segment so sign up today support our
work and we'll see you all there
you